yeah I'm way nicer to black people I me
to white people yeah I was at the gym
one time white guy was playing his music
really loud we're like dude what are you
doing it's a public space it's rude get
get the hell out of here he leaves 20
minutes later black guy comes and he
starts playing his music really loud and
we're all like good Tunes
brother and then I had a guy re go oh
you do that cuz you're scared of black
people I'm like whoa I'm not scared of
black people I'm scared of black
people's cell phone cameras that is
terrifying you know I'm at a restaurant
a black guy's like I got you're like
whoa I said vinegar vinegar what the
hell
salt and vinegar that's a dicey
one I like a dicey Zinger some people
get a weird you know it I like dicey's
jokes anymore is uh TV Riders they've
turned down everything I ever pitched I
pitch this great sitcom about the 911
terrorist but of course they shot down
the pilot but
yeah I know